il attendait cela depuis deux ans et
demi après plusieurs reports mille six
cent cinquante coureurs ont pris le
départ du 80 km de l'eco trail paris ile
de france est forcément les sourires
étaient présents sur les visages des
participants sur l'île de loisirs de
saint quentin en yvelines
sauf un moment qu'on attendait tous à
quoi donc c'est vrai que bon bah ouais
c'est la première grande course - elle
tombe l'été alors que l'eco trail
d'habitude on est sur le mois de mars
mais ouais c'est avec plaisir qu'on
comprend à courir quand on va retrouver
des sensations
pour pouvoir organiser cette 14e édition
les organisateurs ont dû s'adapter face
à la crise sanitaire
les coureurs ont dû notamment partir par
vagues a été une organisation différente
cette année puisqu'en fait on a fait sur
plusieurs départs avec des des modalités
liées aux circonstances sanitaires on
est très content les coureurs en jeu le
jeu au niveau de l'organisation ça s'est
très bien passé des bénévoles qui sont
toujours enthousiaste donc on est
vraiment super content de pouvoir être
de retour
le parcours lui est resté inchangé les
trailer sont notamment passés par
montigny le bretonneux gluant coup
encore vélizy villacoublay en direction
de la tour eiffel il a un dénivelé qui
est relativement
praticable ça n'est pas de l'ultra-trail
mais ça permet quand même de pouvoir
traverser toute l'île de france dans des
conditions qui sont assez spectaculaires
puisque on peut aller jusqu'à versailles
on peut voir des délais des paysages qui
sont vraiment très diversifié on n'est
pas à la montagne mont et cannes dans un
eco trail les meilleurs ont terminé les
80 km en 5 heures et 39 minutes sur le
pont d'iéna
la 15e édition de cette course devrait
être programmée en mars prochain